many actors have retreated from the
spotlight over the years sometimes
setting the stage for a big comeback and
sometimes never to return whether a star
has an illustrious resume or is known
for a single iconic role taking on the
wrong part can be the final nail in an
acting careers coffin
here are some rolls that made actors
quit Hollywood for good pizza Ostrom and
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
the first and only role Peter Ostrom
ever took was the sweetly naive Charlie
Bucket in the original screen adaptation
of Road dolls classic as Charlie Ostrom
was poised to inherit a delicious empire
but after the movie wrapped he stepped
away from the spotlight Ostrom later
told The Daily Express being in the film
industry as a child was hard and I
couldn't keep it going
but in the end leaving was the right
decision ultimately he turned down a
three-picture deal after Willy Wonka but
he remains close to his co-stars even
today using his earnings he bought a
horse
his first step towards his ongoing
career in veterinary medicine which is a
whole lot better than running a factory
notorious for mutilating curious
children Jake Lloyd in the Phantom
Menace landing the leading role in one
of the most hotly anticipated films of
the 90s should have been a dream come
true for Jake Lloyd sadly Star Wars The
Phantom Menace wound up being the first
and arguably the worst installment in a
disappointing prequel trilogy as bad as
it was for viewers though Lloyd's
experience was a complete nightmare
according to Lloyd years later playing
the part made his life a living hell and
a no amount of spinning would help he
was bullied mercilessly when he wasn't
being bombarded with interviews at times
doing as many as 60 a day you still got
all the paraphernalia on your little
figurines if you kept all the all the
merchandise now he shunned it a bit no
just didn't keep the merchandise
following a string of voice-acting paths
for Star Wars podracing video games
Lloyd's most notable brush with fame was
a high-speed police chase in 2015
Jay Davidson in The Crying Game he may
have earned an Oscar nomination for his
performance in the sleeper hit The
Crying Game in 1992 but Jay Davidson
never considered himself an actor in
fact he tried to back out of the role
twice after he was cast a very private
person Davidson had it written into his
contract that he would not have to do
any publicity following the film's
release though he did attend the 25th
anniversary reunion in 2017 upon seeing
an initial screening Davidson explained
to Rolling Stone that it made him very
uncomfortable saying I'm not a performer
do you know what I mean I don't leave
messages on answer phones in case of the
hideous possibility that I will hear my
own voice
Davidson promptly returned to his roots
as a fashion assistant and the model he
appeared in just one other major film
1994 stargates presumably because he
loves the costumes Carey Han in aliens 9
year-old Carrie hen was living in
Lakenheath England where her military
family was stationed when a casting call
for the 1986 space horror flick aliens
rolled through town hen caught the eye
of director James Cameron and though Han
had never acted Sigourney Weaver voted
to cast her as the orphaned survivor
Newt after their first meeting the
chemistry between the two was immediate
cementing the mother-daughter bond as a
central theme of the film after primary
filming had ended and Weaver and him
were the only two actors left on set for
effects shots the two became close she
and I really bonded because everyone
left us and we used to always joke as
they were that were fans nobody want why
would she has found the memories of
filming the gooey bug hunt she never
took another acting paths she did not
want to live in LA after returning to
the States because it would mean being
separated from her family it also didn't
help much
that Newt character was killed off in
hypersleep prior to the events of alien
3 aliens as hen's only IMDB credits and
today she's an elementary school teacher
who occasionally signs copies of the
aliens DVD for his students Heather
Donahue in the Blair Witch Project the
release of the Blair Witch Project in
1999 marks the arrival of found footage
horror a sub-genre which seemingly just
will not die
sadly the career of the film's lead star
Heather Donahue did not have the same
staying power Donahue managed to make a
variety of appearances in indie horror
flicks and on TV including It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia but despite a
convincing performance as a terrified
lost camper she never found a niche in
high-profile roles ten years later she
finally cashed in her chips and hasn't
sought acting work since telling people
I took all my stuff into the desert
relating to my acting career and burned
it all Donahue turns to writing instead
and had her first book grow girl
published in 2012 the memoir chronicles
have experienced growing medical
marijuana on a pot farm in California
she probably needed the stuff after that
one time she totally freaked out in the
woods Sean Connery in the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen you can thank
the 2003 flop the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen for the
retirement of legendary actor Sean
Connery despite the great hype
surrounding this comic-book adaptation
it was a disaster on all fronts and the
trouble started well before the movie
ever saw a screen Connery was reportedly
perpetually at odds with the film's
director Stephen Norrington attention
that resulted in heated verbal exchanges
during filming and post-production it
was the last straw for the screen legend
and this extraordinary mess of a movie
marked Connery's last appearance in
front of the cameras always honoring he
remarks 2gq I was fed up of dealing with
idiots for years there has been a
widening gap between people who can make
films and people who can't his last role
on record happened in 2012 when he
produced and provided the lead voice for
sir Billy which was another critical
disaster for obvious reasons
can this and is good thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]